I'm saying that I'm aiming to go on to college on the same sheets as
I was.  If it's
about money, you don't have to worry about it.I
have such a huge amount of savings-
I don't know what kind of place it is.
That's the way it is
Aoba, come on, money is
n't the only asset in the world, you
're seriously saying,
right
?  The
kindergarten teacher said that work is more important than life,
so I don't want to go that far
.
I'm just saying that I don't want to hit 2000
[music]
That's why the sparrow's tears, right?
5 pieces left to the mountain
Why are you having such
bad conversations when you're all good people? It
's still too early to draw conclusions, right?
]
I
don't want to talk about the sad future,
but I want to talk about the present where everyone is happy
.